well we invite in to answer that
question Florida attorney general former
Florida attorney general Pam Bondi Wall
Street Journal columnist Kim strassel
and Fox News contributor Tammy Bruce all
right Pam let's look at this
uh and let's let's put your legal hat on
your AG hat on okay so we have on the
issue of top secret classified
information we have one system of
justice now we have this whole other
problem that we were discussing earlier
and that has to do with the Biden family
the the one billion dollars withheld
until the prosecutors fired and the sun
continues to get enriched for something
he has no experience in I do believe at
some point this is now go that story
will make it into the political
bloodstream and it may be the dominoes
that now Begin to Fall where Democrats
push Joe Biden out your thoughts
I wholeheartedly agree Sean and as you
articulately laid out already that this
will be a sweeping investigation of the
Biden family and perhaps Rico charges
where they were would be appropriately
filed something else that's going to
happen Sean is when Republicans take
back the White House and we will be back
in there in 18 months or less you know
what's going to happen the Department of
Justice the prosecutors will be
prosecuted the bad ones the
investigators will be investigated
because the Deep State last term for
president Trump they were hiding in the
shadows but now they have a spotlight on
them and they can all be investigated
and the house needs to be cleaned out
because now we know who most of them are
there's a record of it and we can clean
house next term and that's what has to
happen
Tammy let's get your take well you know
I appreciate Marco Rubio's attitude
about worrying about this is going to be
in a way a Tit for Tat but let's look at
how this started you know this
particular environment and the attacks
on Donald Trump did not suddenly just
arise you know out of a a unicorn in
rainbow world where everything was just
fine we've seen this kind of behavior
for Generations coming out of Washington
so you know think about the IRS the Tea
Party Lois Lerner the fact that nothing
happened effectively to people like Jay
Comey and others who did the Russia
dossier hoax you know they go on they
make millions of dollars they write
books and and they Tiptoe Through the
freaking tulips here so of course it
ends up with weaponizing Justice in the
open going after a political opponent
because nothing will happen to them this
kind of behavior is learned behavior it
is reward behavior and it has been going
on for decades Marco Rubio knows this so
the worry is not what's going to happen
after this and isn't that going to be
awful in fact as Pam has noted this is
our opportunity to actually make a
difference to change what it is that's
gone on in Washington and not just
anybody is going to do it it's going to
take a Donald Trump for another term
because this idea of you know holding
Washington accountable is anathema to
anyone who wants to go to the parties
and you know be invited to the White
House and and not have the media the the
drive-by media hate them so this is key
and I think Senator Rubio needs to look
in the larger context of how did this
happen and what are we going to do to
fix it which is going to take you know
repercussions for the people who put
this on us you know and and Kimberly let
me get to you on this because I'll use
I'll use Tammy's phrase Tiptoe Through
the Tulips yeah they seem you know
totally completely Carefree I mean the
people involved in implementing this to
assist two-tier system of justice they
they have this Fearless arrogance about
them that this is just you know the way
things are going to be whether the
American people like it or not they've
got to know in the back of their mind
somewhere if they have a conscience or a
soul uh what they're doing is is wrong
that they're treating one group of
people one way and another group of
people the other way
right and they also have to worry they
have to understand what they are
unleashing here too I mean look I don't
think it's any coincidence that one of
the reasons the hunter Biden's entire
plea default plea deal fell apart is
because they tried to stick an Immunity
Clause in there to make sure that nobody
could go after him over all the
shenanigans that went into the first
deal if the Department of Justice
changed
um and you know look we do want to have
an honest standard of Justice one
standard of justice for all but I do
understand Marco Rubio's fear here too
that we are crossing some sort of line
okay I mean it's one thing the
Department of Justice and its
politicization but what happened in
Georgia this really is a new ball game
we've long had a standard that you know
if you were a federal politician accused
of some sort of serious crime or maybe
the Department of Justice would get
involved there are thousands of
prosecutors Sean across this country
at the state and local level that if the
the new standards anyone can go after a
federal official on the the most
stretched of racketeering charges I mean
this is a very scary new place
yeah all right uh exit question I'll ask
all of you the same one Pam I'll start
with you and it's very simple is with
all that we know about Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden and you know the money
they're making from countries like China
and Russia and Romania and Kazakhstan
and Ukraine
um and Joe leveraging the the billion
dollars and Hunter getting paid and no
experience and he's addicted to drugs
well anything ultimately happen to Joe
and Hunter Biden regarding these issues
what is your prediction Pam
have a new a new Administration
absolutely Sean it has to Joe Biden we
now know had three aliases they had 19
shell corporations set up that is a
criminal investigation that must be open
good job
Alan dershowitz said Congress can
appoint a special counsel can they
they can Congress absolutely can they
have subpoena power but nothing is going
to be done to be prosecuted they do not
have prosecutorial power investigative
power until 18 months when Donald Trump
is back in office and I think that's
what Marco was referring to frankly
Tammy same question well I believe that
only if Donald Trump is elected there
will be Justice and there will be
genuine investigations as we've seen as
I've mentioned it's been a long time
that Republicans have had power it's
gone back and forth and we haven't seen
anything significant happen to the level
of corruption that's in Washington D.C
so I don't think it's going to be just
any GOP president I think we're going to
have to be looking at at least to get
the ball rolling uh four more years of
Donald Trump
Kimberly same exit question
you know we're talking a lot about legal
issues which are important I want to
look at this in a slightly different way
which is that there's another power the
power of the people to punish
politicians via elections why did Joe
Biden work so hard in his team to make
sure we couldn't find out what was going
on in Hunter Biden's laptop Etc prior to
the last presidential election because
he feared that it would be enough to
make sure that he was not elected we're
going to have these house investigations
and aside from the Department of Justice
and what comes down the road the
American people are going to have the
ability to render their own punishment
on Joe Biden if it turns out he's been
untruthful about what went on with his
son all right Pam Tammy Kimberly thank
you all appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else